The narration of
in the chapter regarding vigilance of
Allah authored by
that after he asked the prophet Sam
what is Islam?
Islam.
[Silence]
So he asked tell me about Islam. Define
it for me. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said Islam is that you testify
that none is rightfully worshiped but
Allah and that Muhammad is the messenger
of Allah. That you establish prayer that
you give zakat. That you fast the month
of Ramadan. and that you make pilgrimage
to the house of Allah thea
if you have the ability and means to do
so. And so this man responded
you are correct.
And so Omar says we were taken aback
and perplexed that he is asking the
prophet sallall.aii wasam but then he is
confirming his answers as if he already
knows the answer.
He said, "Tell me what is eman?" And the
prophet responded saying that you
believe in Allah, his angels, his books,
his messengers, the last day, and that
you believe in decree, good and bad of
it, both the good of it and the bad of
it. or that you believe in Allah's
decree, the good that Allah decrees and
the bad that Allah decrees. And so the
man responded,
"You are correct." Again, he is asking
and then he is confirming as if he
already knows the answers. When we look
at this narration,
we see that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam here when he was asked about
Islam
he spoke about things that are outward
things that are manifesting
prayer everyone can see that this is an
outward action right fasting
which is an action that a person does
it's an action of refraining but it's an
action it's a conscious refraining
giving
zak going to make hajj testifying
of a shahad and these are outward
actions. And then when he was asked
about emen, he mentioned a series of
beliefs which are all inward, right?
Belief in Allah, belief in his angels,
belief in his books, belief in his
messengers, belief in the last day, the
day of judgment, and belief in the
decree of Allah, the good of it and the
bad of it. This is all belief. So what
does this mean?
Islam and eman are part of a group of
words in the Quran and in the Sunnah.
These words when they are mentioned
together
they separate in meaning and when they
are mentioned separately
they converge in meaning. Okay. These
words are defined by the scholars
very very curiously as
[Silence]
Okay, these words are very numerous
throughout the Quran. Books have been
written on these words. And these words
are something that we need to go out of
our ways to learn these words, these
sets of words. There's many of them.
These words, when they come together,
they have different meanings. Meaning
when they're mentioned together in the
same
context, in the same situation, in the
same sentence, in the same paragraph
this, Islam is mentioned and then
iman is mentioned. They're mentioned
together. They have separate meanings.
But when they're mentioned separately,
okay, just Islam is mentioned alone or
just iman is mentioned alone for
instance, they have the same meaning.
these definitions here. Islam and Eman
are two of those words
and for instance
they are of these words the names of
Allah many of them
when they're mentioned together they
mean the same they mean different things
when they're mentioned separately alman
means ale as well and ale means man as
well
and so forth. There are many of them
throughout the Quran. This is important.
Why? Because in order for us to
understand the Quran
and not to misunderstand, we have to
know these words
im and Islam. When Allah mentions the
believers,
it is the believers that enter paradise.
Inahkari
and Muslim the prophet Sam
announced to the people
only a believer will enter paradise.
This is easily confused by people as
meaning just someone who believes in
their heart. There's no belief. You know
they don't pray, they don't fast, they
don't do anything of Islam. They just
believe that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah. Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah. But it does not
affect their actions at all. Can this
person be a Muslim? Absolutely not.
There is no such thing as iman without
Islam and Islam without e. A person who
is only Muslim but does not believe in
his heart but he goes through all the
actions. Is this person a believer? The
answer is no. Because when these things
are mentioned separately, they entail
one another. When they're mentioned
together, they add context and they
enrich each other.
Same thing when you read in the Quran,
those who believe and work righteous
deeds. Sometimes you'll find the people
that enter paradise are the ones that
work righteous deeds. Doesn't mention
belief. Sometimes you'll see belief
without righteous deeds. When they're
mentioned separately, they mean both.
When they're mentioned together, it's
additional what? Addition additional
detail, right?
For instance,
ms when it's mentioned by itself, it
means as well. And al when it's
mentioned by itself means ms as well.
But when they're mentioned together,
Now they have different meanings because
they're mentioned together.
This detail is so important because you
see this start to give color to the
Quran and to its meanings and you see
how intentional and deliberate the
wording is.
So for instance, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
mentions
in the Quran about loot and his family
right and
he mentions that there was only a
household of Muslim
right but Allah saved the m he mentioned
them together
so he mentioned muslim here outward word
actions. When Islam is mentioned on its
own, it means eman. And when eman is
mentioned on its own, it means Islam.
But when they're mentioned together,
Islam is outward actions. But eman is
inward belief. So if we were to look at
the people of Medina, the prophet's
time, sallallahu alaihi wasallam, it had
believers and it had hypocrites. We
would say these are Muslim
and these are the m
right so the hypocrites would be
described as muslim in this context
because it's mentioned together etc
he said so tell me then about
in the Arabic language
if we say
what does that mean linguistically.
Huh?
You said something, huh?
[Arabic recitation]
in the mind. That's not what it means.
to tell you something. Here's an
exercise. This will help you.
Whenever you are asked what a word
means, the first thing you do
is you search your archive of the Quran
where that word is mentioned.
for instance.
Uhhuh.
[Silence]
Allah describes himself now as the one
who
in a past tense everything that he
created.
Let's look for a similar meaning in the
Quran.
[Silence]
we could say,
but it's the same meaning.
So,
and she
[Silence]
is something that unfortunately
Many people when they first become
religious, if they were born Muslim,
they first make a conscious choice to be
a a believer
or when they enter into Islam from
disbelief.
They are very excited. Their mind, their
heart is a sponge. Anytime Allah's
name is mentioned or his prophet's name
is mentioned, their ears perk up.
They're excited.
And then what happens?
And then time goes by and time goes by
and time goes by and slowly slowly what
happens?
The novelty wears off. The hard the the
heart becomes hard. Slowly over time and
then 20 30 40 years will pass by and
nothing has changed about them. Nothing.
Here's a tip. The way that eman works is
it never stagnates. Never. Eman never
stays the same. With every single moment
you are conscious, your eman is moving
in one of two directions.
Always.
It's either increasing or it is what?
Decreasing. There's no such thing as
just being a sane. That doesn't happen.
If you're not increasing, you are
decreasing. Kind of how major
corporations look at their money and
business models, right? We have to what?
We have to have exponential growth every
single year because if we do not have
growth, we are actually losing ground
because someone else is growing. That's
the way they look at it. That's greed,
right? as greed which is not okay with
the dunya which is absolutely
acceptable with the
and so your ean is never the same. My
ean when I sat down here and when I get
up is not going to be the same. It was
not the same. I've either done something
that increased my faith or I've done
something that decreased it. The only
time my eman will maybe stay the same is
when I'm sleeping, when I'm unconscious.
But as long as I am conscious and I am
of age,
my eman is either growing or shrinking
at every moment.
And so what is al
is that you are able to gain more than
you decrease over time to the point that
you perfect.
You are giving given mastery
over your dean which is something we
will discuss tomorrow inshallah
subhanahu waala.
for
[Silence]
speech.